we're going to start it off with loudoun
who joins us in portland oregon loudoun
you're
on the dave ramsey show how can we help
uh hello uh thank you for taking my call
so uh how are you guys doing today
well we're living the dream what's going
on with you
um so i'm pretty i'm pretty much doing
the same so i'm a 16 year old in
portland oregon
um i've basically dedicated my life to
school
i'm going to school to get my associates
of science right now at the local
community college
and i have a part-time job i just
finished summer term
and now it's basically turned into a
full-time job for about the next
month and then i jump back into school
so
um i have college pretty figured out
it's getting paid for
and then i think i'm probably going to
be attending west point i'm applying
there
and doing all that so i was wondering
what do i do with all this
excess income that i have that i'm not
spending because i have my budget
and all my six months of expenses and
stuff wow congratulations first of all
can we say this young man chris has got
it together
louden where did you learn about money
did your parents teach you
um well partially but they actually have
some really bad habits
um so it's sort of just listening here
and then i'm just talking different
people
um i'm sort of looking at a roth ira
with some people but
i just don't like their how great is
that alright so before chris dives in
let me just ask you how much money are
we talking about excess
and then what are your big goals as a 16
year old because you're a guy who's
thinking about this
oh yeah so i want to go to west point
and then after i do that i want to
probably serve my 20 so i can get my
pension and then
i'm excited um there's two paths i don't
want to go up congress
i've always been very politically
motivated and i kind of want to go that
path
or i might go up the economic side and
be a financial advisor my ultimate goal
is to sail around the world
i i just think he needs to aim a little
higher with that loudon quit being lazy
okay no listen here buddy i absolutely
love your energy i love your drive
and i'm going to tell you without a
shadow of a doubt i believe you can do
anything you set your mind to
um i think the smartest thing you could
do right now with money
is to save some and what i mean by that
is boost up that savings you're working
hard being very intentional
and then begin to invest i want you to
connect with a smart vester pro
like you said you want to find someone
that's going to talk with you about your
dreams and help you on the financial
side
but i want you to do this for me i want
you to remain
absolutely allergic to debt and what i
mean is that way your income stays freed
up to do the things you wanted to do
i like the idea of you saving it up that
way if you want a car you can upgrade
the car
but begin to save begin to invest and be
very intentional with your money
but get connected to a smart festive pro
go to daveramsey.com i love that young
man what a great call to start with okay
hold on a second
have you ever talked to a 16 year old
that
focus and knowing their path no no
i haven't either i was already impressed
at west point then he said it well after
that i
i want to run for congress and congress
could probably use a young man like this
i completely agree but we digress and
then he said i want to sail around the
world
sure why not he said that like me going
to the grocery store yeah yeah i may
want to sail around the world
okay wow oh i love that what a great
call thank you louden
uh what and by the way just a quick
little thing for those of you that are
in these older generations i i
i get weary of hearing people my age
poo poo young people like they just
don't have it figured out let me tell
you something there are eagles and every
generation loudon is one of them i
completely agree hey
uh kelly let's do this i feel feel like
santa oh here it comes here it is
i'm going to beat ken to the punch i
want to send loudon a copy of ken's book
proximity principle because this young
man has some massive dreams and i want
him to know how to get connected with
the right people in the right places
and i'm going to double down and give
him a copy of my book
everyday millionaires because i have no
doubt that this young man is on the path